[Music]
on this friday night
on the record a senior naval officer
testifies about trying to expose
sexual misconduct i was berated in a
very demeaning manner
and the defense minister on the defense
global news uncovers more disturbing
allegations aimed at canada's military
how one woman says she was silenced
basically
shut your mouth and carry on fears for
the future
it is really important still to be very
vigilant
new anxiety over the rise of the
variants relaxing restrictions
and a third wave plus hiring spree
signs canada's economy is rebounding
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us there are troubling
details tonight about the investigation
into allegations of inappropriate
behavior at the military's highest level
a house of commons probe into the
allegations heard from senior defense
staff today
including minister harjeet sudjan and
lieutenant commander
raymond trotter military police are
investigating former chief of the
defense staff general jonathan vance who
has denied any wrongdoing
and the man who took over from him
admiral art mcdonald
has temporarily stepped aside pending a
military police investigation
sources tell global news trotter is the
senior naval officer
who reported an allegation of sexual
misconduct
against mcdonald last month and has
received anonymous threats since
global news first brought you details
about those allegations
and today we heard what trotter
experienced when he decided to come
forward with what he knew david aiken is
following the story for us tonight
david well robin four hours of house of
commons defense committee testimony
today and
at the end of it we have a disturbing
first person account
of what can happen to a whistleblower
trying to complain
about sexual misconduct in the canadian
forces
you know i have four young children i
have a wife who is a registered nurse
student and so i have concerns
lieutenant commander raymond trotter
says he's had
threats that his navy career might be
over after he reported
allegations of inappropriate conduct by
the military's highest ranking officer
chief of the defense staff admiral art
mcdonald i understood it was my legal
and also my ethical duty as an officer
to report these serious allegations
trotter told mps on the defense
committee he was acting on behalf of a
female colleague
and he said he found the process of
reporting a complaint about a senior
officer confusing and difficult it was a
very discouraging and disappointing
experience
in this environment i can certainly
understand why so many victims of sexual
misconduct
would be reluctant to come forward he
has since been involved in reporting a
separate complaint of inappropriate
behavior by another
senior naval officer and he said after
he did that
he was yelled at for doing so by one of
his superiors
i was berated in a very demeaning manner
for following through on my reporting i
believe i was treated this way because
the complaint
was also about another senior officer
still too many members of the canadian
armed forces do not feel safe to come
forward
but defense minister harjit sajin came
under fire for not doing enough now
nor three years ago when allegations
about former
chief of the defense staff jonathan
vance were first raised
that in 2018 both you mr minister
and the prime minister knew that there
were allegations
of sexual misconduct against the chief
of defense staff and neither of you took
any effective action
so lots of digestion four hours of
testimony but a key takeaway
even senior officers like trotter say it
is difficult
to report a complaint to an independent
authority
that is outside of the military chain of
command
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
canada's defense community is facing yet
more allegations of sexual misconduct
within its ranks
a department of national defense
employee has come forward to global news
with an account of her experience
not only as a canadian forces officer
but as a civilian
in the department of national defense
our auto bureau chief mercedes
stephenson has the exclusive details
mercedes robin alex eau claire says
she felt she had no choice but to
abandon her dreams
of a lifetime career in the military
after what she describes as a shocking
experience as a combat arms officer
in 1997 she says that she was one of two
women
in a class of 200 soldiers at cfb
gagetown in new brunswick
where she says she was forced to shower
with the men
eau claire says she reported her
experience at the time to a general in
ottawa
who told her to stay quiet if she wanted
a career in the forces
she became a civilian with the
department of national defense
but before long eau claire says she was
sitting across the table
from some of the very same men who had
acted so inappropriately
during her time as a soldier she says
the military's overly sexualized culture
has seeped deep into the department
where many executives
are former officers eau claire also
shared details of an alleged sexual
assault
she says she experienced at the hands of
a department executive
but she says she was discouraged from
filing a formal report
i tried to report it and
the answer i got was that because there
was no
did i have any dna evidence did anybody
witness this
if if the answer was no and if you still
needed a job
it was his word against mine and so
basically shut your mouth
and carry on eau claire says she hopes
that her story will empower other
civilians
who've experienced sexual misconduct in
the department to come forward
and it's a call for change in the
canadian defense establishment that she
believes
is so desperately needed robin mercedes
stevenson in ottawa
the liberal government is
re-establishing an advisory panel to
pick the next governor general
intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc will co-chair the group
with janice cheret a former high
commissioner to the united
kingdom the advisory group also includes
inuit leader
nathano bed they're responsible for
submitting a short list of candidates to
the prime minister
two months ago julie payet resigned from
the position after a scathing
workplace review the prime minister had
some good news today about canada's
vaccine supply
pfizer has confirmed it's ready for a
major ramp up in deliveries
canada will receive at least one million
pfizer doses
per week from march 22nd to may 10th
a million doses of pfizer alone
every seven days that's going to make a
big difference
over the last week nearly 600 000
vaccine doses have been administered in
canada
that's the highest weekly total yet more
than 2.2 million canadians have now
received at least one dose
that's about 5.8 of the population
there's still a long way to go to get a
vaccine to every canadian who wants one
with new variants spreading the
government is urging people
to be cautious right now we need to run
the mile we are in
and keep to a steady cautious pace
that's all continuing to support
team vaccine by not providing any
opportunities
for team variant to gain more ground
eric sorenson has more on the spread of
variants than what could be in store for
canada
as warmer weather approaches a sunny day
foreshadowing spring is a new variable
in a pandemic that continues to evolve
warmer weather should mean less indoor
transmission of viruses
but spring also brings more socializing
among canadians
we know we're heading into the period
where the transmissibility will decrease
and we know we need that social
connection
in bc groups of up to 10 people can now
gather outside with distancing
in ontario some gatherings like weddings
can now be held outside with up to 50
people
cautious first steps to making life
normal again
but with the worry that canadians will
let their guard down we're all anxious
for the finish line
on this long marathon but right now
racing towards the village
could cost us a success we've worked so
long and hard for
what could undo the progress we're
making are the new covid variants
they're now responsible for over 40
percent of the cases in ontario
while the reproduction number for the
early variants in the province has
fallen below one
which means it's going away the r number
for the new variance is above one
meaning transmission is increasing so
while the rate of infections with the
early virus has been coming down for
several weeks
the new variants while fewer in number
so far
are on the rise which is why the total
number of cases are no longer
making progress in fact a third wave is
not out of the question
i liken the state of the pandemic right
now in canada as
a third act in a three-act action movie
in the third act we fight the biggest
foe
so the biggest foe here is the threat of
a new variance but the end is near
the end is near restrictions are being
lifted vaccines are coming
it all potentially sends a signal to
canadians to let loose
but the cry from public health officials
is not yet
as we see those public health measures
ease i think it is
really important still to be very
vigilant about
these variants ultimately say experts
it's up to canadians to maintain
sensible restrictions on themselves
we can restrict our socialization
sufficiently
to allow vaccination time to do its job
it's a tricky balancing act
as spring arrives with the hope of
vaccines in the air
canadians should resist throwing caution
to the winds
erik sorensen global news toronto
in ontario health authorities are taking
aggressive steps to get an outbreak at
an amazon facility
under control the facility in brampton
has been ordered to close and all
workers must self-isolate for 14 days
according to the region's top doctor
thousands of people
work there it's not clear how many
positive cases are involved but the
health authority says the rate of
infection has been
increasing significantly in the last few
weeks
if you're hoping to do your taxes this
weekend and need access to your online
cra account you may be out of luck the
cra says it plans to temporarily lock
800 000 accounts tomorrow the agency is
calling it a precautionary move
there's concern that usernames and
passwords could have been obtained by
unauthorized third parties the canadian
economy has been hit hard by the
pandemic but there are some signs of
optimism
last month 259 000 jobs were added
across the country
the unemployment rate dropped to 8.2
percent the lowest it has been
since march 2020. in alberta the
province with the second highest
unemployment rate in the country
this news is important as fletcher kent
reports
this might be the restart it so
desperately needs
restaurant owners thomas and char
feuster are still in business
given the last year that's their
definition of success
it has been stressful as hard as 2020
was there's some
optimism now barb and ernie's in
edmonton reopened to diners in february
and hired back half its staff
next couple months we're already looking
like i said i think my july will be full
capacity
well that's hopeful this week the
conference board of canada projected
alberta will lead the country this year
in economic growth
in new statistics canada data shows
alberta is one of eight provinces to see
job growth in february
nearly 17 000 new positions were created
in the province
most of those in the hotel and
restaurant sector unemployment is
below 10 and while that's the lowest
rate since the pandemic began it's also
the second
highest rate in the country behind only
newfoundland and labrador
i think we should be optimistic but i
think that we also need that healthy
dose of
caution economist moshe lander says
getting back to where alberta was
is welcome but it's far from great
alberta and its all-important oil and
gas sector faced
problems before kovid vaccines and
reopenings won't fix those
the fact is that what's being left
behind is that residue is
is the problems of the alberta economy
not the problems of the pandemic
but even in oil and gas there's hope as
the world reopens demand for gasoline
and jet fuels expected to climb we've
been able to
bring back a number of people been able
to start taking care of some families
that
went through some difficult times mom
and dad lost lost their jobs
yet more concrete examples of these
latest employment statistics
a snapshot that highlights both growing
optimism
and the many struggles still ahead for
albertans fletcher kent global news
edmonton a man believed to be ndp leader
drug meat singh's brother-in-law
has been charged with assault
this twitter video is part of the police
investigation it shows a man pushing
another man
at a canada india friendship car rally
in brampton ontario
jodhpur delhi deliwal is charged with
assault causing bodily harm
his lawyer tells global news he has no
comment as the case is before the courts
the ndp leader wouldn't comment either
tensions have increased within the
indo-canadian community because of the
farmer's protests in india
there are accusations some sikhs who
support a separate state in india
are causing trouble the city of
minneapolis has agreed to pay george
floyd's family
27 million dollars floyd died when a now
former police
officer kneeled on his neck for nearly
nine minutes a statement from the
family's lawyer says
the settlement which is the largest ever
reached during a pre-trial
sends a powerful message that black
lives do matter and police brutality
against people of color
must end scientists keep discovering new
things about covet 19
coming up the evolution of the new
coronavirus
in patients with compromised immunity
plus
smooth moves the ice cleaner heating up
the rink
scientists in the uk believe the b-117
variant originally came from a single
immunocompromised patient a person who
would have had a harder time
fighting kova 19 making them a vessel
for the virus to incubate
and mutate tonight pharah nasser
explores how effective the vaccines are
against any new mutations and this is
the virus spike protein here
even world-renowned expert ravi gupta
was surprised by how the novel
coronavirus
started to change you know we'd been
we'd been learning for
a year that this virus didn't change it
was always the same there were a few
mutations here and there
and yet in this person we saw just the
most dramatic shifts you could imagine
as the variant from the uk started to
take hold gupta saw a patient
sick with covid for more than a hundred
days
his body weakened by previous
chemotherapy the virus not only wouldn't
leave
it kept replicating again and again
when we discovered this there was
nothing known about variants we didn't
know that you could find
viruses with so many mutations in one
virus gupta and a team of researchers at
the university of cambridge took
continuous samples as the virus mutated
in the man's body
but one of the mutations we found led us
to discover the b117 variant because
this mutation in our patient that had
emerged in response to treatment
actually was one of the key mutations
found in the b117
the patient sadly died but from this
case
scientists gained important clues about
what we know now as the more infectious
b117 variant and it's 23 mutations
there are a growing number of cases
showing evidence of immunocompromised
covid19 patients
accelerating viral evolution now
research is being done
to see if those with low immunity will
be protected by the covid vaccines
this also raises questions about
vaccines overall
what is the research showing about how
effective these vaccines are
against the variants so if you look in
in certain kind of
test tube experiments you'll see that
the variant from south africa for
example
does have a reduced response to the
vaccines
especially astrazeneca but if you look
more closely you still have
way more antibody than you need to
neutralize it vaccine manufacturers are
exploring booster shots and other ways
to bolster covid19 vaccines against
variants of concern
but for now it's a race against the
viruses sequencing superpowers
and scientists rushing to keep up with
it
farah nasser global news toronto
there are a growing number of variant
cases tomorrow in the new reality we
explore how that's possible
that's at 7 pm with donna friesen right
here on global still ahead netflix won't
chill
the streaming giant is on the watch for
password freeloaders
you're watching global national
[Music]
an ice cleaner for the vancouver canucks
is sweeping the nation with his moves
his skills went viral after the nhl
posted the performance online
the canucks say the sweeper named devin
has been with the team for four years
fans joked the team could use his energy
during the game
not between breaks ouch harry and
megan's popularity has
taken a hit for the prince it's an
all-time low in the aftermath of that
interview with oprah winfrey
where the couple shared what their life
is like inside the royal family
and claims of racism according to a poll
done in the uk
48 percent now hold a negative attitude
towards harry
while 45 have a positive view of the
prince
and 58 say they have a negative opinion
of megan
if you've been using someone else's
netflix account you may need to get your
own
the streaming service is testing ways to
crack down on password sharing
some users in several countries
including canada are getting pop-up
messages like this
if you don't live with the owner of this
account you need your own account to
keep watching
netflix says the test is being done for
security reasons
the stay at home reporter up next mike
drolet gets
personal about the pandemic
living life during a pandemic has been
hard on all of us
tonight mike delay reflects on how his
own family got through these
difficult times i haven't been down this
driveway
in a year 12 months of working virtually
hasn't been easy
but i'm one of the lucky ones who's kept
his job and stayed healthy
when the pandemic hit the furthest thing
from my mind was documenting my life
where i see me is in the stories i tell
about others
so this is what i made oh nicely done
i'm impressed mike from the outset we
looked for distractions
he's running the bases the pandemic
puppy helped fill a void
and brought some much needed laughter
into our lives but the isolation was
unavoidable
virtual school zoom hangout with friends
all of it made us want to be
more attentive parents it's refreshing
in many ways the pandemic year was the
reset on our priorities that we needed
everyone gets distracted be it from work
or just life in general
and with an only child the fear was how
the toxicity of 2020
would shape her going forward you see we
have a precocious eight-year-old
the last thing we want is for her to
fear the world
but on the flip side we didn't want to
shelter her from what was going on
in those times when i needed clarity i'd
jump on my bike and hit the trails
and no i never really found it and maybe
that's the lesson i've learned this year
don't overthink anything enjoy what we
have
knowing that others have endured more
hardship and that this virus
has taken so many lives
because the ballet studios will open
again soon
at least my little ballerina will be
ready
micro by global news toronto
very sweet story that is global national
for this friday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is peggy's cove
in nova scotia we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night